[Musique]
bonjour la réunion bonjour le monde
entier comment ils les six ateliers bien
moins les mieux alors dont on n'est pas
sorti de l'auberge aujourd'hui on est à
montvert les bas juste en othe grand
bois et on va voir pierre et pierre rime
avec bière exactement de la fabrication
de bières artisanales
alors tout ça avec modération on est
bien d'accord
et vous allez me suivre tout de suite et
plus vite que ça
on y va on y va on y va on y va en vain
[Musique]
on a
ici
[Musique]
quand il le faut
bonjour pierre bonjour à l'ex-amant il
est pas mal et où même super ben déjà
merci d'accueillir le plus grand plaisir
alors dis moi où est ce qu'on est s'il
te plaît est ce que tu fais bien sûr je
fais de la bière artisanale et ben voila
qu'osama 10 au total de la avec
modération bien sûr bien sûr un temps
tout le temps tout tandem vous devez
modéré on a une phrase non en belgique
parce que je viens d'un petit peu de
belgique
en tout cas j'ai été formé là bas c'est
une bière brassée avec savoir se déguste
avec sagesse en comble mignot dis moi tu
va montrer tout ça oui
moi j'ai envie de voir exemple je suis
un gros curieux et bas à l'essai par
niveau on a beau être vérifiée
[Musique]
à
donc là ici vous voyez déjà les stocks
de matières premières parce qu'il faut
savoir quand même qu'une bière est fait
avec différentes matières premières
justement tu veux ma prendre parce qu en
fait j'y connais rien ouais mais pas
tout le monde ne connaît effectivement
alors y en a 4 c'est du malt d'orge
c'est la céréale
il ya du houblon ça c'est pour donner
l'amertume est certaine saveur de l'eau
bien évidemment c'est une des plus
importantes forcément et de la levure
qui va pouvoir transformer le sucre en
alcool bien plus tard dans le dans le
process de production d'accord donc
voilà les éléments pour faire une bonne
bière
je suppose que les différents dosages
appartient au secret professionnel assez
ça c'est sûr que c'est certain ça c'est
le secret du brasseur à chaque recette
on a chaque qualités différentes
matières premières à des dosages
différents fin voilà il ya une
personnification de la recette qui est
hyper importante et qui fait partie de
la valeur ajoutée du brasseur doit vous
avez vu et il veut pas dire que je
l'aimé pas il veut pas dix mois toute
cette matière première
tu penses que tu fais venir ou alors
est-ce qu'il ya une partie locale alors
malheureusement sur les matières
premières que je viens de citer il n'y a
pas de production localement mais
justement si on parle du houblon j'ai un
projet en tête qui peut être verra le
jour
j'espère c'est d'avoir un houblon pays
je suis persuadé qu'ils seraient
exceptionnellement bon et qu'on pourrait
même avoir une renommée internationale
grâce à séoul on l'a oui parce que là
c'est vraiment la richesse de la terre
qui va s'exprimer
mais forcément la réunion c'est génial
ben oui paraître la réunion du jury
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
le croate
[Musique]
donc là on a cette fameuse matières
premières donc des céréales bien sûr
c'est du malt d'orge ont cassé voilà il
a été mal tu es et nous on va le
concassé ce qui va nous donner quelque
chose de presque farineux mais pas trop
parce que sinon sa bouche le filtre et
c'est donc ça qu'on va pouvoir mettre
dans la cuve matière et la gougoune
globalement on voit ya à peu près 2 135
kilos de grains de céréales pour cette
recette d'aujourd'hui ça va nous
permettre de faire mille litres de bière
donc il faut s'imaginer 3000 canettes ça
va voilà exactement
mais si magnifique moi je dois rêve
l'ange doublée d'une volonté je te
plante et tu vas prendre sa voix la
mettre dans la machine qui est là voilà
alors ça c'est la cuve matière ou ap le
mans ou simplement appelée cube
d'empaquetage donc on va verser dedans
il ya déjà de l'eau à une certaine
température et là on va faire la
première étape qui consiste en fait à
transformer l'amidon en sucre s'appelle
l'empaquetage et donc pour faire ça on
va s'arrêter à différents paliers de
température et y aurait une réaction
enzymatique qui va se passer à
l'intérieur qui va pouvoir justement
transformer tout ça j'ai l'impression
d'être dans une
j'ai une série où il étudie la biologie
la physique laboratoire de 2,2 de fou
comme la pierre oui je n'ai qu'une chose
de dire fesneau de la bière à
l'enseignement
[Musique]
c'est toi qui as fait le mélange on est
bien d'accord je vais dire les
différentes doses des différentes doses
de chaque céréales tafer
[Musique]
j'appuie j'appuie est ce qu'il ya des
éléments quand même locaux dans ta bière
bon tu vas me dire look tout à fait tout
à fait j'essaye quand même d'intégrer un
maximum d'éléments par exemple dans ma
bière blanche
on va avoir d'accord rien de pays et des
zestes de différents agrumes pays et en
fait j'ai découvert que historiquement
certaines familles réunionnaises brasser
de la bière ici dans la famille et ils s
avec du margose pour remplacer le
houblon
je rêverais de faire ça aux merguez
[Musique]
donc là je vais utiliser mon four caire
le fourquet c'est la cuillère du
brasseur ça va me permettre
en fait de brasser le malt concassé que
j'ai mis dedans parce qu'il peut faire
éventuellement des petites boules ce qui
serait dommage donc grâce à ce fort
qu'est à la forme très caractéristique
on va pouvoir casser ces petites boules
[Musique]
ça va brasser là combien de temps là on
en a grosso modo pour une heure de temps
pour faire la partie en partage d'accord
après je vais transférer liquide dans
une autre qu une cuve de filtration qui
va me permettre en fait de récupérer un
liquide sucré qui donnera beaucoup plus
tard la bière est par contre j'aurai en
déchets tout le tout la fibre des
céréales qui donc ne me servira plus à
rien et celle là je la donne un éleveur
pour que lui nourrisson partout le son
bétail et c'est comme ça riera
[Musique]
là on va faire la partie ébullition
c'est à dire faire bouillir pendant une
heure et demie avec beaucoup beaucoup de
feu et c'est là qu'on va rajouter le
houblon qui va donner l'amertume de la
bière et une fois que ça c'est fini on
va passer sur la partie froide
donc c'est à dire qu'on va transférer up
par là bas en fermentation écoute on va
pouvoir commencer par ailleurs
[Musique]
bana congo
petit taxi le vol
une fois qu'on a entonné notre liquide
nos 1000 litres de produit on va en
semences et c'est à dire rajouter de la
levure jusqu'à maintenant on n'avait pas
du tout d'alcool en un liquide sucré
avec du sucre rapide qui étaient
extrêmement bons mais toujours pas
d'alcool donc la petite à petit up
l'alcool va se faire pendant à peu près
cinq à six jours si je voterai blanc
taché mois la documentation primaires
primaires après on va faire la
fermentation secondaires qu'on peut
appeler aussi décantation à froid c'est
à dire que autant la fermentation
primaire on l'a fait aux alentours des
20 degrés autant la décantation à froid
je vais redescendre très très très froid
entre 0 et 2 degrés et là je vais
laisser entre quinze jours et trois
semaines
[Musique]
alors là on est un endroit où tout ce
stock je reviens petit peu c'est un truc
moi tu bosses seul tu fais ta bière tout
seul mais bien d'accord je fais tout
tout seul donc soit la production
brassage conditionnement fermentation
les tests et tout comptabilité tout ce
qui est gestion comptabilité commerciale
relance des clients et ses tournées de
livraison aller voir les clients tester
de nouveaux produits
allez voir nouveaux fournisseurs
organiser la logistique tout il est
musclé
on n'a pas cela
[Musique]
la blonde aromatisé au miel d'accord eh
ben tu sais quoi bon donc
je vais te poser des questions répond le
plus longtemps possible pour que je
puisse apprécier fait un plaisir
comment en es tu arrivé là un jeu dire
j'ai commencé vraiment tout petit tout
petit perdu dans mon garage à vincendo
fpt donc j'avais une toute petite
brasserie greffet avec mes propre main
beaucoup de bricolage et cetera
et puis petit à petit j'ai développé
l'entreprise les marchés les cafés
certains clients qui ont cru en moi j'ai
déménagé il ya cinq ans en fait dans ce
local qui à l'époque était beaucoup trop
grand et maintenant il est beaucoup trop
petit donc c'est plutôt bon signe
il ya trois ans j'ai fait un projet
d'investissement et qui a été
subventionné par le feder donc la région
l'état et l'europe pour l'achat de biens
d'équipement dont on a fait le tour
d'accord mais moi je vais aller encore
plus loin mais tu sembles écoles
d'accord comment tu dit écoute moi j'ai
envie de fabriquer de la bière je veux
dire je dis à tes en france et déjà je
suppose tout à fait j'étais en france et
j'ai commencé là pour le coup à brasser
dans ma p'tite cocotte dans en
colocation donc je dévastait
complètement la cuisine pendant 6 7
heures j'avais des produits d'une
qualité approximative mais c'était hyper
sympa ont partagé ça avec les colocs
on se faisait plaisir c'était rigolo
comme tout comment on reconnaît une
bonne bière alors déjà avant du service
il faut que la mousse se constitue bien
et donc c'est le corps jusqu'à c'est le
cas c'est assez content il ya deux
choses à la constitution c'est le fait
d'avoir un beau dôme et le fait que ça
reste voyez depuis tout à l'heure qu'on
parle la mousse elle descend pas elle
bouge pas donc ça veut dire que tout va
bien
il ya autres un autre aspect sur la
mousse c'est quand on regarde au dessus
si ça ressemble à des petits blancs en
neige ça veut dire que la mousse est
très dense ça veut dire qu'on a une
bière de très bonne qualité
après il faut sentir la bière très
important parce que ça peut dégager
énormément d'arômes qui sont plus ou
moins intéressants là on est donc sur
les notes un petit peu sucré c'est le
miel qui a été rajouté qui va donner
quelque chose à ses sympathisants sont
en fleurs presque ça sent presque
lafleur est effectivement équipe
et puis bon bout d'un moment on nous a
titillé nous a titillé faut quand même
bien
un se lancer et de la mode et à quoi ça
ressemble d'accord et donc là on va
avoir une attaque sur le palais il ya
les bulles qui vont éclater et qui vont
donner un premier goût et après on va
avoir une longueur et c'est deux
éléments peuvent être complètement
différent sur les recettes
ben écoute pierre à la fondue alex les
bons et en hockey avec grand plaisir car
ça allait
[Musique]
où
il y fait
[Musique]
ici
on est en face de l'ancienne usine de
grand bois zéro calebasse à fumer doit
en bois bon ben voilà on avait un petit
peu la fabrication de bière artisanale à
consommer avec modération à marjah on
est bien d'accord
là je vous vois attention modération je
vous dis tout simplement à la prochaine
au revoir salute et caetera et j'ai
oublié
on n'est pas du tout sorti de l'auberge
non messieurs that my n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge du tout parce que là la moins
chère contenir ou miss o
[Musique]